hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
we're going back to school again and
covering the topic of jitter
it's a common technical buzzword that
people throw around
whether it's people selling you cables
or
tweaks for your audio or people talking
about measurements and what have you
so i thought i'd dig in and actually
tell you what it really is what it's not
how we measure it what are the
audibility
aspects of it because there's just
tremendous amount of confusion
on what it is the concept applies to
digital to analog converters a dac
if you look at the simplified picture i
have here in one of my old older
articles
uh you need a few ingredients to produce
the output of
of a digital analog converter uh it
needs the audio samples
obviously but it you know those just
digital values and
tells the dac produce this value then
produce this value then produce this
value
the dac is running at certain sample
rates so if it's running 44.1 killers or
sensibly you need to have 44
100 samples a second so there's a
thing called the clock which paul says
and says go
and output comes out and then it ticks
to the next one
and another output comes out and takes
and takes and ticks
and the analog comes out what the
dac does is that it also has what is
called reference voltage which i won't
talk about much
today but it can look like jitter uh
contribution
um in that it takes this reference
voltage let's say it's
three volts and then it divides it by
the steps that you tell it so
this sets the sort of maximum value and
then when you give it a digital sample
you're saying give me a ratio relative
to that
this needs to be quite accurate
obviously this uh
reference voltage if it's not uh
accurate then
you know you're obviously going to
produce garbage and
uh turns out this is hooked up to a
power supply that's also
been driven by the rest of the system
and noise gets in there
it can also output impact the analog
output of the dac
likewise if clock pulses their timing
varies if they're if they
run slow or fast it's all right that's
our ears not very
sensitive to that if it runs even one
percent too slow or too fast
but if it moves back and forth it
modulates
these samples and produces an analog
output that just got distortion in it
this is not a good picture i'll
show you actual demonstration with audio
precision analyzer later on
so this is the concept that we're
focusing on
which is clock pulses and can they get
the
jitter induced to them and
what that looks like and what have you
now the uh
father of of uh a digital audio
uh one of the most famous uh uh uh
fellow by name of julian dunn he worked
for prism sound and then later on audio
precision
and he's responsible for a lot of
specifications on digital audio and
i recommend that you go and download
these papers you have to pay
unfortunately i don't think there are
free copies of it out there
but on the engineering society you go
there and just look for julian dunn and
jitter and these titles i'll put a link
in the description for them
but he did a simple math he took
the mathematics of of jitter which is
a sinusoidal assuming you have a sine
wave and you
mess up its uh timing with another sine
wave
basically what happens is that the phase
of that time that
uh sine wave gets modulated yet again
this is a gnarly formula to try to
resolve and i'm not going to walk you
through it but you can read the math
but it's done some simplifications and
turns out you can predict the uh
interference that you get from uh jitter
and uh and it just becomes proportional
to the uh
frequency of your source signal and
turns out if you just have
500 picoseconds of of jitter
is enough to step on the lowest bit in a
16 bit sample
so what is the pick a second is one
trillionth of a second so very very very
small
number so one nanosecond would be one
billionth of a second so
half a billionth of a second is enough
to disturb a 16-bit signal
and i'll show you again examples of this
so and that's for 16 bit for 24 bit
signals this number becomes ridiculously
small like 10 or 20 picoseconds so
uh as much as its timing value is small
the distortion that it generates is is
big and if you can grow
what this says it basically says if you
have a source signal
and you modulate it very small amount by
modulates timing you wind up with two
side bands one above and one below
and these are the distortion spikes that
are
unwanted and we don't want in our signal
so the
harm of jitter isn't that the timing of
the signal moves back and forth you
often see
youtubers or journalists show you a
visual picture where they take a picture
like let's say my hand and they blur it
out multiple times and superimpose them
and say this is jitter
it is not how are you going to see a
timing difference of a billionth of a
second
you're not right that thing is not
moving in time a billionth of a second
or
you know to cause problems or nobody
would listen to lps and
and uh and uh tape decks and what have
you so
it is not a timing problem our ear is
not
anywhere close to sensitive enough to
hear this as a timing problem
but it can hear this as a distortion and
an
artifact so julian don went on and
came up with a clever test signal um
the sine wave uh is it it's it's not a
good signal to
to use for testing in general because
it's a mathematical function that it has
these fine gradations and
you can convert it to integer values
which is what the digital audio
is but he came up with a simple uh uh
way to generate a very pure sine wave
without it being a sine wave
and what it is actually a square wave so
and it's
and it cycles between two hexadecimal
numbers
if your computer science if you're not
don't worry about it so basically we
have a square wave
the square wave for 48 kilo sampling uh
it's always one-fourth of the sampling
rate so 48 kilos which is what i use for
testing
one-fourth of it's 12 killers so we have
a square wave running at 12 kilos
remember what i said about square waves
if you chop off their
spectrum above the main frequency you
actually get a sine wave
so indeed if we have a 12 kilo square
wave but we chop off everything above
24 kilohertz which is the bandwidth that
we have
in a 48 kilo sampling everything gets
thrown out and we wind up with a pure
sine wave and all we had to do digitally
if we look inside of
this signal which is called the j test
or jitter test all it has a square wave
in it
that that goes from this to this now he
was clever
in that he added one more thing to it
250 times a second he adds
one bit to the number and he subtracts
one bit
to the number so what happens that this
number goes from
c000 to bff
so just think of this as if i go 9999
and add one to it it becomes 10 000. so
all the digits have changed
if i take one away from 10 000 all of
them becomes 999.
the amplitude change is infinitesimally
small yet it generates a lot of activity
all the bits have to toggle
and when all those bits toggle if there
is jitter we get to see it more often
so a common misconception about j test
is that it actually
creates jitter it by itself can't create
jitter because it's just a file that you
play
literally i'm not going inside this dac
and injecting jitter into his clock i
have no access to that
all i can do is feed it a signal and we
happen to pick a signal
that is a easy to create and b
we're constantly toggling his bits
without changing the form of that
signal that ultimately is reproduced by
the by
the stack so
what does that look like if we just took
a spectrum of j test signal
and band limited it so we're not looking
at the harmonics of square wave so we
see that pure
12 kilos tone that i talked about so
that's what this spike is
this is our wanted signal inside of it
as i mentioned we're also 250 times a
second
we have a square wave what is the
spectrum of 250 hertz
square wave it's 250 hertz and then
three times higher 750
and then five times higher and so forth
and the amplitude goes down
now this is visible in here because the
audio precision
here is analyzing a digital signal so it
has no noise so i'm able to go to minus
180 db
very very low noise floor to expose
these even state-of-the-art dax can't go
this
low as a result you usually don't see
any of these maybe you see the first
second but you don't see any of the
other ones so as a
typical rule when i run the jitter test
you want to see this
and basically nothing else because these
other ones
are all in the noise floor of the system
anything else is unwanted and if it's
jitter it will show up as symmetrical
tones which i'll show you in a second
hopefully with you're with me but i
think it's important to understand what
a jta
test signal is that we use for this test
again it has no
jitter in it a digital file sitting on
disk
is constant it can't have variations and
it's not sitting there dancing around
it's just a set of numbers
we play those set of numbers and it's
two square waves nested in each other
they go on the dac what comes out of
that is actually a sine wave because we
don't let all the harmonics come out
and then we capture that analog waveform
and we apply spectrum analysis on it
and we see what that looks like so
let me switch to my audio precision
analyzer
and show you what's going on so this is
a
um oops let me uh get rid of this title
here so you're not confused
so i've got an spl uh phoneter x
that's a 2500 dac and headphone
amplifier i just reviewed it tonight
unfortunately has a very poor dac
section in it
very disappointing is what you find in a
10 dac
i don't know what's up they claim to
have a very good deck implementation but
certainly wasn't the case here so i uh
couldn't get the usb port working but
toslink optical works so i hooked up
toslink and i
you can get i got this display but
notice what happens now i've got a usb
cable that's also connected to it so i'm
going to plug this in
i'm not going to use usb so this is
still configured to receive
data over toslink and my audio precision
analyzer is sending a toslink data
so let's go ahead and and
go ahead and run the this usb notice
what happens how noisy it got
this is actually clean um when i run it
during the review the spikes were just
far far worse than this um maybe i can
stop this running one more time see if
we get lucky
and uh it shows the watchforce input
nice insisting i'm not doing that but
anyway you can see that there's a lot
more activity now
here than there was so mere fact of just
hooking up a usb
cable to the unit allowed
some activity from my computer to bleed
into there
and that leaked into the dac and
produced
all these extra noise in here like you
can see there's more noise in the
lower case of lower section of this
display
so oftentimes when i run this display
it's not really a jitter
test it's actually just anything garbage
our wanted signal again is this over
here the spike here
all this other stuff we don't want and
if they bleed into this we don't like
so let me disconnect this and
delete the uh usb one
so this audio precision analyzer is
quite clever
in that i can take the uh
the any of the digital outputs the
toslink and coax for example
and i can tell it to wiggle their clock
so it can actually induce a
created noisy uh interface as if you had
a really cheap source
that didn't have a good clock accuracy
and
i turned that on i can tell it what i
want that the jiggling to look like the
jitter spectrum
um for sake of simplicity we're going to
say sine wave we're going to say one
kilohertz
and i'm gonna say add four nanoseconds
to it so four billionth of a second
and let's see what happens when we do
that
notice what's going on now look at these
two pulses in here
you know the signal is at 12 kilohertz
we get one
at 11 and we get one at 13 kilohertz
why do we get one on 11 and 13 because
the side bands that show up as jitter
are the sum and difference
of of 12 kilohertz relative to our
jitter frequency
so if our jitter frequencies one
kilohertz we get one
at 12 minus one at 11 and 12 plus one at
that
so if i then change this to four
kilohertz
uh oops four kilohertz and you'll see
that
uh we should get one at 16 kilohertz now
and we get one at eight kilohertz right
so four plus our tone four minus so
often times when i run this if i see
something like this i'll tell you
there's a jitter frequency
at eight kilohertz and uh or four
kilohertz and
you know this is how i know what the
jitter frequency is
because i look at the difference between
these and i can see it there
now notice how tall the spikes are i
mean if this were distortion
we're already up to -92 or so i mean
minus 88 or so
even though we only added 4 billionth of
a second
worth of timing difference four
billionth of a second really really tiny
amount
the distortion spikes are quite high i
mean we many dags have harmonic
distortions so way below this and here
we're generating distortion products
that are really tall
worse yet we're distorted generating
distortion products before our signal
in addition to after the way
psychoacoustics works is that
there's a shadow that the signal
generates a stronger signal generous
that masks
the audibility of things in front of it
much more than masking things that are
below it so as a result these tend to
become more audible
than the ones after harmonic distortion
is always after so they guess mask
more than equivalent jitter would so
jitter is not
a good you know signal if you will for
uh
to have in there as far as distortion we
want to have a lower threshold there
um so we also have a choice of spectrum
so instead of a sine wave i'll change it
to square wave
and uh let me change this back to one
kilohertz
and let's see what we get
now what happened when i just it's one
kilohertz when i had just a sign as the
spectrum only got two spikes but the
moment i changed it to a square wave
why did i get all these other ones
remember what i explained the square
wave to be
right is one pulse plus harmonics
forever
each one of those sine waves in a square
wave
generates its own jitter this is
important because
these devices are what we call mixed
signal they have a digital input that
receives digital data
and some of them have microprocessors in
them and so forth and
all of those digital circuits work on
square waves
so if they're going to interfere with
the rest of their circuits
oftentimes that interference in the form
of a square wave
so you can easily see a train of these
pulses in in this jitter spectrum and
whenever i see that i notif i mentioned
in my review that hey there seems to be
a square wave interference
because i can recognize this kind of you
know uh
pattern to it uh as opposed to as you
know just as pair that would be for sign
wave
now i can also change this to be noise
and noise uh it's it's also a
common interference a cpu that's running
inside this device it's doing so many
random things
that's activity may not be just a simple
here's a pulse
you know it's just many many many
billions of operations second is doing
notice what happened when i changed this
to noise
i no longer get the individual spikes
why because noise has every frequency
known to man
therefore it raises the noise floor of
the system proportionally
so a jitter one it has a spectrum of
noise
that means it's randomly changing the
clock it basically just
raises your noise floor by equivalent
amount
and it's very benign you can see how
much it impacted my system
just a few db i laws nothing like those
tall spikes that i was showing you
when the spectrum was a sine wave of a
square wave
so random noise tends to be uh
more benign and sometimes the noise
is not broadband like this and it you
see it here where the bottom of this i
call it the skirt
widens i call that random
low frequency noise that means it's
random but
it's not you know quickly changing is
slowly
randomizing the the clock
um now question is how audible are these
things
uh you know they a lot of people are
very scared of jitter they think it's it
can be quite audible um
the there hasn't been that many studies
into audibility of jitter believe it or
not
and the the main paper there are two
papers
one that tested random jitter which i
just showed you it's not an
issue and therefore you don't want to go
chasing
random random jitter and
uh because it just raises the noise for
a little bit and
is very blind so that's a bad study so
if you run into that one
which with google you'll see the paper
you'll see it the second one you
probably
can't find it is on aes and uh
was done by eric benjamin and benjamin
uh
gannon um when they were at dolby
laboratories
and they uh examined jitter this is a
pretty readable paper much better than
julian duns and
they go through what kind of jitters you
know exists in typical equipment they
measure it
paper is 30 years old so the equipment
they tested
you know measured are very very old um
but then they did a cool thing which is
they perform a listening test
and let me scroll down it's just a few
pages down so you can see you know
what's the threshold
what's the you know lowest amount of uh
we can detect and uh they came up with
an interesting test in that they uh
had a way to use a function generator
and take a clock and
and and literally change the uh clock uh
of a dac and and be able to change the
uh
either drive it with uh you know sine
waves or whatever frequency they wanted
uh they went through a good training
session and booted out the people that
could they were just
too deaf to hear artifacts and that's a
good thing to do many of these studies
they take everybody and
glom on their results and you get people
who don't have good acuity
for uh small impairments and uh
they wind up diluting the results so let
me scroll down to
uh what was going on so they first
tested what would happen if you just had
a sine wave pure sine wave playing
and then you had another sine wave that
was jitter and
which then try to you know add jitter to
that
so in this case uh they have a four
kilohertz
signal um and uh
they're looking at the jitter amount
that was the threshold now this is not a
blind test that you the listener
literally had a knob where they could
turn the jitter up and down
and where they thought there was they
could hear they said i heard it and that
number was
registered so it's not a statistical
double-blind test
where we could tell these results 100
valid but directionally they're probably
okay
we see that with four kilohertz the uh
thresholds are very high we're talking
hundred nanoseconds over here for many
of these listeners
but as the frequency went up we see
there was one listener here that his
threshold was down to four nanoseconds
of what i just simulated was four
nanoseconds
uh jitter so he was able to hear there's
some error bars in here so it was as low
as
uh two three nanoseconds and five or six
nanoseconds
and then there were some people that
were you know couldn't hear it as well
so these are the listener numbers
nine listeners but you can see that it
is frequency dependent
uh in this thing and then
uh 20 kilohertz around the test and then
they've
switched from running sine waves as a
test signal to running music
and they have different tracks that they
played from these uh different uh music
this
again 30 year old music i don't know how
many of you remember this blockbusters
uh synthesized uh music it was one of
those reference cds when cd format came
out
and now you can see that the jitter now
in a second the thresholds are insanely
high we're talking 60 even
listener 2 he's now up to 90 60 120
330 seconds nanoseconds
so music tends to mask a lot of these
artifacts especially if the person is
not a critical
trained listener it's just going to be
hard to hear artifacts so
oftentimes you see people say well all
these tests are with sine waves with
music you can really hear artifacts
no simple signals bring out artifacts a
lot
easier than complex signals because
complex signals there's a lot of
spectrum in there that masks the
audibility of distortions
in there so you know that is not a good
argument at all
um whenever we use a lot of cycles
psychoacoustic research
music is much less critical content as
far as threshold of detection
for artifacts than than simple sine
waves
okay sorry about the denseness of this
topic i just wanted to make sure that
you knew the true fundamentals of it so
just summarizing don't use your
intuition
it is a time in jitter but it's not
blaring things in time it's not screwing
up
transients the moment you read that in
the marketing material for anything just
skip past that because that person
doesn't know the hell they're talking
about
yet ninety percent of audio tweaks for
digital audio for cables or
stuff to put under it or or fancy that
they talk about how
transients get better now has nothing to
do with timing it has to do with the
spectrum of music they can get corrupted
um i measured i've measured 400 dax
i can't maybe one or two of them had
objectionable jitters so far it's very
audibility so it is
you know it's a solved problem but it's
still
as you saw with this device there are
people still not doing the right things
that bothers me so i measure it and i
show it
um we show it with this j test signal
that is supposed to
aggravate the situation but it doesn't
literally cause any jitter it's just a
signal like any other digital data
and just happens to be specially made
with a square wave that's that's rather
clean
and that we like to see a clean spectrum
i don't want to see a whole bunch of
unwanted noise from the rest of
the processor in this thing or usb input
or a dsp
in case of an avr what have you bleeding
into the dac it's a revealing test from
that point of view
okay so hopefully you learned a new
topic and if you did i bet you you know
more than 99
of the audio files who haven't watched
this video okay
we'll do some lighter weight videos
after this one
see you in the future one bye